[Music]
tracking down and prosecuting the
estimated 2 000 suspects involved in the
january 6 attack has turned in one of
the biggest investigations in the
history of the fbi so far more than 700
people are facing criminal charges after
investigators scoured tens of thousands
of hours of video evidence but the
professionals could not do all of that
alone in fact they relied on help from
the public and that includes an
interesting group of amateur detectives
our jefferson spoke with members of this
group they're secretive understandably
they're worried about threats themselves
jeff good morning what do you know good
morning tony the so-called sedition
hunters are amateur detectives who come
from all walks of life a teacher who
squeezed in research between classes a
union worker even a grandmother but they
all have one thing in common the horror
that they felt on january 6.
that day is seared in so many minds
mobs of rioters
pummeling and beating police officers
and trying to breach capital doors
i was watching all these people hurt
officers desecrate congress and no one
was getting arrested what this woman saw
on january 6 motivated her to do
something we aren't identifying her
because like others working to identify
rioters she's concerned about her safety
what happened means something to you
well a democracy is only as healthy as
its citizenry in a democracy its
citizens have to care
they have to care about the rule of law
reading through tens of thousands of
images produced that day this
politically independent grandmother
joined the crowdsource collaborative
movement of sedition hunters almost
immediately was there one in particular
that sickened you caveman who beat
officer miller with the with the flag
pretty much anyone in the tunnel that
day
participated in mass mob violence john
scott railton was also closely watching
the attack one image stopped me in my
tracks and that was a picture of a man
wearing body armor holding a clutch of
temporary restraints in the visitor's
chamber of the senate i thought my god
what is going on in the capital of my
country railton an internet researcher
focused on hacking and disinformation
got to work trying to identify the
masked man looking at the image what is
this guy wearing what's he carrying how
does he move
and through that process which would be
called open source investigation
ultimately we got to an identity railton
motivated others to start sifting
through the mountains of evidence
available on tv and social media people
began joining groups and collaborating
with each other that ultimately led to
some really remarkable discoveries and
successes to me it sounds like finding a
needle in a haystack
it's like finding a needle in a haystack
of needles some of this addition hunters
would work with images just focused on
tracking people in the crowds others
focused on building timelines or
geo-locating individuals on maps of the
capital it's like looking at a picture
what's in the background where do i
think the person taking this video was
standing what else in that video
corresponds to a time period that i
already know they even established
ethical guidelines of what not to do for
example they don't name individuals
before an arrest has been made
the group's findings including nicknames
they gave to rioters have ended up in
charging documents and fbi case agents
continue to ask for the public's help
any assistance in this kind of
assistance is really vital former fbi
agent catherine schweitz says the
sedition hunter's work has undoubtedly
led to faster results it is by far the
largest number of people that the fbi
has ever had to investigate the fact
that the citizens are stepping up is
taking the time period and shrinking it
down substantially still there remain
more than 250 people wanted by the fbi
for allegedly assaulting federal
officers and ultimately the number of
arrests could more than double you know
that old saying many hands will make
light work with the help of the sedition
hunters grandma's got new hobbies she's
got gardening hobby in the spring summer
and fall and sedition hunting
hobby in the winter time if i a simple
little old gray-haired grandma
can do this anyone can
the people we spoke with believe that
there are hundreds if not thousands of
people doing this kind of work and
they've gathered tony this
massive database 1800 images and even
names
of some of the people that they've been
able been able to track down and it's a
huge amount of work for law enforcement
i know this investigation could go on
for years to come they could still be
tracking people down bringing charges
but before we look into the future i'm
interested in the past you were here on
january 6th what are your memories of
that day
i will never forget how all of it
started i was at the ellipse where the
rally was and as soon as rudy giuliani
took the stage and said trial buy combat
and then the president took the stage
you could see the the tone in the crowd
changing they came this way in fact
there was a man beating on our cbs news
truck and he looked like he wanted to
hurt us
but once we were able to get out of the
truck we came up here and then of course
i saw people climbing the walls
harrowing memories of 365 days ago jeff
thank you very much